ميدان المعركه الروسيه الاوكرانيه مشتعل
في تصعيد مستمر منذ الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير الماضي ثلاث مراحل تنوعت فيها
اشكال
واستراتيجيات القتال من قبل الجيش الروسي
ومرحله الرابعه على وشك البدء وقت وبراء
المرحله الاولى هي التي تعثر فيها الجيش
الروسي في كياب والمرحله الثانيه هي التي
تحول فيها القتال من كتاب الى اقليم
دومباز اما المرحله الثالثه فهي استعاده
اوكرانيا لخاركيب ومدينه في جميع تلك
المراحل قاتل الجيش الروسي بالخطوط
الخارجيه على جبهه ممتده ملكيه شمالا الى
خرسون جنوبا مشاكل نقص الامداد وغياب
القياده الموحده لكل جبهات
القوات الروسيه ستبدا مرحله الرابعه بعد
ذوبان ثلوج الشتاء وهدوء عواطفه ابرز
ملامحها قد تكون العوده الى اسقاط العاصمه
كييف عبر بيلاروسيا مع تقييد الهجمات
الاوكرانيه في خاركه وخرسون والتركيز على
احكام السيطره على كامل اقليم جمباز مع
محاوله استرداد الاراضي التي يسيطر عليها
الجيش الاوكراني في الاقاليم الاربعه التي
ضمها الرئيس بوتين وخصوصا زابوريجيا
وجه جديد للمعارك قد يشهد كذلك دخوله بلا
روسيا الى المعادله خاصه ان بعض المؤشرات
تقول ان روسيا بدات ارسال القوات المسرعه
اليها مع نشر منظومه صواريخ اس 4
والصواريخ البالستيه من نوع سكندر ملوك
الشيخ العربي